so uh for this talk this is going to be
uh talk is going to be with harini
and so both of them work at IBM and
harini is a senior technical staff
member at
IBM hi
good good
morning
[Music]
good morning everybody can you hear
me yeah my name is you can call him Guru
uh we're going to present this uh work
that we've been doing for the last year
or so um and it's on um you know using
Foundation models to predict above
ground biomas and the goal is nature
based carbon sequestration so let me
just quickly go over the agenda here so
we're going to split this Stu uh so I'll
talk about the problem statement and the
IBM geopal Foundation model approach
it's only uh you know 30 minutes is our
talking time so we not going to be able
to go into a lot of the details um there
are some Publications coming out uh so
we can always point you to papers um and
then Guru will talk about the rest the
data sets the challenges that we face
you know that's not a trivial problem uh
the various experiments how we measur
performance and some results
too
so um some numbers here um so 50 billion
50 billion is the number of tons of
carbon dioxide that is being you know
emitted I think in um into release per
year into the atmosphere so if you do
back at the envelope calculation that
that would require us to plan 1 trillion
trees to come to this
okay 148 billion is the cost of climate
related disasters just in 2021
and uh like many of us 75% of consumers
today are very climate aware when they
make purchases and the main thing here
is also the 68 trillion so that's the
amount of money that climate conscious
investors are you know funding so so
sustainability is a big problem and we
actually are coming from the IBM
sustainability software Division and we
work on a series of problems and this
particular team we are are working
on many natural uh you know uh nature
related Solutions we do all prediction
that WEA is a key component we gave a
talk last year and earlier we spoke
about couple of my colleagues here spoke
about I using you know a lighter and
satellite imagery to find proximity of
uh vegetation to power line because
that's a fire hazard and this talk is
most about is about nature based carbon
sequestration as we all know you know
the the most efficient way of converting
carbon dioxide into carbon biomass or
whatever is nature so you plant more
trees you can absorb more carbon dioxide
uh you also have the carbon dioxide
absorbed on the uh you know in water
there is by fighter plant is mangrove
that's called blue carbon today's stock
is more on the you know the soil Caron
so whatever is being absorbed by trees
so that's the high level
okay so what is the problem statement
here we want to really predict how much
carbon is in any area given a we call
let's use the geospacial TB there is a
polygon some area on the earth you want
to see how much carbon is there that's
our goal and while you know and we'll
come to there are lots of manual ways of
doing it but our goal is to make this
information reliable scalable so that we
can take any polygon on the globe and be
able to see how much carbon is there in
that in that you know in that area there
are manual approaches okay the real way
of doing is to sample some trees burn
them down say how much carbon is there
okay that's not obviously the right
thing to do but there are also people
who are there are lots and lots of
vendors companies out there particularly
in rainforest areas like the Amazonia um
in Africa you know where a lot of
Destruction has happened and they
actually go and measure the you know the
tree trunk they measure the tree height
they know what the species is they EX
samples by Hector and then they
calculate what's called above ground
biomass there are eletric equations the
forest tree people if anybody's here you
better than me you will know that there
are these allometric equations that take
these basic quantities and it can
compute what the biomass is the biomass
is not necessarily in the leaves it's
mostly you know in the trunk in the
branches and there's also biomass under
the ground all the roots are all carbon
right so so that's a general formula
some percentage of the above ground is
the low ground biomass um and then there
is that's the mass and from that you can
convert it to carbon because A45 or .5%
of the biomass above ground biomass is
the actual carbon so then when they do
these samples then they take those
samples and extrapolate them to other
trees in the field okay so that's how
they calculate the biomass now so to go
further so as you can see they do this
manual local assessment it's labor
intensive it's also can be error prome
you know but uh the ground Roo is great
you know most of the time they have good
ground Ro but it doesn't scale so there
are various machine learning techniques
out there to actually take satellite
imagery data and uh and you know use
some ground tro data like height and you
know you calculate the biomass in
specific areas and then you can label
you can label data and then you can
compute the biomass uh you can build
models to compute biomass and uh so
satellite imagery wise is it useful
because it'll uh give you you know and
Guru will go into the details of the
specific kind of satellite imagery that
we use but it can give you not just the
RGB it can give you all the infrared
bands and it'll be able you can actually
detect vegetation you can detect you
know and that based on the penetration
of the various imagery you can actually
see how much volume of you know uh Leaf
which kind of translates to um the
biomass so
so what is our approach we want to build
like as we call Wall toall estimates of
aboveground biomass density in an area
and what we do is we use multispectral
satellite imagery uh and we continuing
to improve on the input images so it's
not just satellite imagery of one flavor
multispectrum but we're also looking at
radar imagery here but what we are also
using is as labels is the industry
established abound biomass density
labels are will go into the details of
that as well so um what we doing then is
that we're building you know while we
can build a model per region using that
region satellite imagery and whatever
labels we have we want to be able to
scale this so this is where the
foundation model approach comes okay so
very quickly I think everybody
knows this is the you know uh the pitch
for traditional models you have labeled
data you have you know AI models for
each task
Foundation models is where you have
different kinds of input data and you
know we know everybody understands this
very well I mean almost a good extent
with for text images videos Etc you
build a pre-trained model that is
self-supervised model and then using
that you can build a whole bunch of
Downstream Tas so in the tradition or
not I wouldn't say traditional but in
the circle for the type of inputs that
everybody is familiar with like
languages images videoos we do you know
Q&A translation sentiment analysis code
generation for example uh they are all a
bunch of Downstream tasks that can be
implemented as fine tune models now and
you know I don't want to go into the
details of this because this is well
known people have published this what we
are specifically working on is uh using
the you know input satellite imagery and
we call them geospatial Foundation model
this is a big effort in IBM research and
uh we only partially involved in the
pre-trained geospatial foundation model
model learning work itself that is
primarily done only by IBM research at
this point where they're taking you know
these large amounts of this
multispectral satellite imagery and
building pre-trained models which is
like you know essentially learning the
relationships between the bands
temporally spatially Etc and this is
like huge volume of data right now we
have actually built models for across
the globe using this pre-train model we
can then have a bunch of we actually
have a bunch of Downstream for
segmentation or for classification our
specific problem is to find aboveground
biomass so it's a regression problem so
what we want to do is estimate you know
what is the forest biomass using the
pre-train model as input and we have um
you know the fine tune models in between
okay that makes
sense
um
so the you know so when we build these
Foundation models they are built
globally and then for a specific fine
tune task we get the corresponding label
data so the pre-rain model is the
foundation model Global then for a
specific task in our case aboveground
biomask we get the labels for that task
and then we tune the pre-train model
using um using this label but there's a
lot of work that goes in between and
Guru will go into the details you know
we have to process the input data uh we
have to harmonize the data with the you
know with the label data do the modeling
and then you know um you know train tune
test whatever and then deploy them and
we have an INF INF engine that can score
the model and then we can do some um you
know process afterwards that will take
the biomass density calculate the carbon
and build some statistics on top so
that's that's the approach that we are
using
and before I hand over to Guru who'll
talk about the data sets the challenges
uh experiments we done any questions so
far on the problem statement or the
general
approach all right let me hand over to
go you you can feel free to stop us they
need time and ask
questions okay so uh I'll just talk uh a
little bit about the data sets for our
biomass
estimation so the uh most important data
set that we have is called the hls or
it's called the harmonized lat Sentinel
2 so basically it's a it's a kind of a
satellite imagery which is at 30 m
resolution so each pixel in the in the
image is 30 m uh and U this this
harmonized lands side imagery it it's
available all over the globe and it
comes in forms of tiles and each tile is
uh 3660 X 3660 pixels that's roughly
equivalent to 110 and by 110 km and uh
it's available
all across the globe and also every few
days so that's a very useful component
of this satellite imagery that you can
use this to chart even uh the changes in
different features on the earth so and
it's freely available uh from NASA so
it's one of the very useful data sets
that we have from
NASA so I'll just like to show you uh a
sample of this image so it will be more
uh clear and intuitive what I'm talking
about so we have this a geospatial tool
which we use called qgis so here uh I'm
showing an image uh from this hand
harmonized landside Sentinel 2 so you
can see this is in form of a tile and uh
behind the image I have a Google uh
satellite uh um view of the of the same
area on Earth so you can see that when I
click on any particular point on this
image I have these 10 band values here
so basically every hls image it has uh
different wavelengths for each pixel so
it can be red blue green and there are
some other wavelengths like near
infrared uh short wave infrared and um
wavelengths which the visible ey cannot
see uh I'll go uh into that in a minute
but you can see that uh it has values
for all these 10 bands and this gives us
a lot of uh information hidden
information which can be useful to
predict a lot of stuff uh and biomass
being one of them so let me get go back
to
the so as I said that uh this imagery
has um wavelength from red blue green uh
up to a certain wavelength it goes into
uh the short wave infrared so you can
see the visible spectrum and you can but
you can also see um um ranges outside of
the visible spectrum and um this
satellite is uh equipped with special
sensors which are able to uh measure
this wavelength and sometimes this
imagery is also called hyperspectral
imagery so now uh as I mentioned uh uh
we have all these different bands as I
showed uh 10 bands on on the software
for our purpose uh usually we only use
six of these bands so blue green red and
uh near infrared which is close to the
INF
and then we have something called as
shortwave infrared 1 and two the
difference only is that the wavelengths
for these uh uh W are slightly
different so and these are available all
from NASA so this was uh all about the
satellite imagery that we use as the
training data now let's talk about uh
lar data so liar is actually a data set
which is uh is also remote sensing but
it's basically laser pulses which are
being transmitted from a sensor to down
to the Earth and it is very useful to
measure uh distances uh between objects
relative to other objects relative to
Earth and it basically creates like a
three-dimensional map of any particular
place on the earth so it's a very high
resolution data set and uh main thing is
that it it's very expensive to procure
uh so it's not available uh as easily as
the satellite Ma um and usually uh there
are some sources where you can get it
for free there are some publicly
available lar uh and sometimes you have
to uh buy this kind of data basically so
um we have something called as uh uh ji
from NASA which is basically a global
ecosystems Dynamic investigation it's a
initiative by NASA which basically uses
liar so they have this sensor placed on
the International Space Station and they
send the laser pulses to the Earth and
they cover the whole globe using that
that those laser pulses every few days
and so they have like a map of the whole
world and it's a very useful data set
that NASA started uh the only thing is
that it's not very uh uh dense it's a
little bit sparse and uh there are some
challenges with the accuracy of of this
data as well which I will get into uh in
a minute but uh this data set uh has few
different products the two main uh
offerings from this data from NASA one
is the height information so basically
you can tell what is the height of the
canopy or height of the tree on any
point on Earth uh and the second one is
the uh above ground biomass density what
we refer to as AG BD so basically that
is how much biomass is present uh in in
one particular uh area on Earth and
usually they derive this biomass also
from the height so uh these NASA guys
they have some kind of models to
extrapolate the height to the biomass uh
they work with forestry experts
University researchers and they have you
know people going into the field and
they they have something called as
eletric equations which are just uh
equations which relate the height to the
biomask so they use those equations and
they come up with this biomask number
and this is a very useful data for uh
you know researchers because we can use
this uh as a training uh data label and
we can uh interpolate this data to uh
regions in the world where we do not
have this
biomass so uh as I mentioned this is uh
placed on the ISS and this uh this is
what the the sensor looks like on the
ISS and basically this is how the points
the lar points look on the surface of
the Earth so basically it's in form of
straight lines and in each line every
every uh point is separated by around 60
M and um every point is a 25 M footprint
so that means that when the laser hits
one particular point the area that it
covers is around 25 M in anying One
Direction and then the separation
between uh two lines is around 600 M and
so using that liar uh they estimate the
height of all these points and using
these height the they extrapolated to
get the
biomass
okay so
now so now I'll uh talk about the
challenges that we face with this data
sets so uh the first uh challenges that
we have with is with the uh hls data
that I talked about earlier so uh and
it's also an artifact for usually any
satellite imagery so because it's a
satellite imagery and we know that uh
everywhere on Earth there are clouds at
any point whatever image you take there
will be clouds in that but clouds poses
a lot of challenge for doing machine
learning data science or any kind of
data related work so uh we don't want to
have clouds so we have a way of dealing
with that so basically it's like we take
different images from different
timestamps for the same uh area on Earth
and uh we have a method to combine them
into into one composite image so you can
see that there are these white uh pixels
are clouds in this image every image has
clouds but when we combine them uh there
are almost no clouds in the final image
so this is a very important step uh
because it gives us a lot of uh uh data
which otherwise we would have discarded
right so um and also one one uh
important point is that for the purpose
of biomass uh since we only want to look
at um areas or times when there is
actual uh leaves on the trees right so
we only uh take these images which fall
inside the time range when there are
leaves on the trees so this time range
uh will vary for different regions on
the earth depending you know on the
growing season and all of that um and
also uh this biomass will requires um
this cloud-free imagery for a continuous
prediction right so if you want to
predict a biome for any area on Earth
for let's say uh you know 2 years 3
years or X number of years so it has to
have a continuous input of that imagery
from those uh months uh whatever the
date range for that area might be uh yes
why do you only want to look at it when
there's leaves on the trees so as I said
uh if there are no leaves on the trees
it won't give us accurate representation
of the biomass because leaves also have
uh biomass in them and actually that is
the main U Main uh data that we are
using to estimate the biomass because
there are different the leaves will have
different colors and as I said it's not
just red blue green but there are other
wavelengths that we can't see right so
if there are no leaves there will be
basically uh inaccurate data and it
won't represent actual biomass that the
tree can store basically did I answer
your question but it doesn't store that
biomass year round it's only when the
leaves are on the trees that it's
captured that so the biomass actually uh
stored changes um over the year right so
during the growing season if they have
leaves they will store more biomass and
when the leaves go off the tree will
still still store biomass but it will be
less because there are no leaves right
so the biomas will change over the year
and technically we can measure uh we can
like measure biomass even when there are
no leaves but most of the problems we
are interested in are during the growing
season and also we want to estimate the
capacity of that area to measure to to
store the carbon or store the biomass so
that's only possible when you look at uh
the leaves included the other the other
thing is that some of these as you were
saying the in prodct bands will help us
get a vegetation index so veget you know
there's vegetation which means there is
you know a tree there could be something
else like grass or shrubs but that's
where you know the label data will help
us so because the mass will be higher
when you have like a bigger tree uh so
the reflectance from the leaves you know
is basically coming from these bands
that are in the
satellite thank you and one more thing
the leaves trees don't grow that fast so
when you even if you look at month over
month change the growth is not that much
it's more the we if you ever want to see
month over month change it's more like
you know sudden destruction fire has
happened and that will also count yeah
so in that actually that case uh if we
see that uh there are no leaves on the
trees and suddenly or there are no trees
right will look like a deserted sort of
thing or deforested thing uh we we can
actually input that to the model and it
will give us a prediction of the biomass
and then you can say that oh the biomass
has decreased so much so uh it's a way
of actually measuring deforestation as
well any other
questions um I wanted to ask about uh
how uh climate change has affected uh
you know
a lot too so does that impact the uh the
industry in any way or yes so actually
uh that's a good question and the whole
reason we are doing this is ultimately
to measure the effects of climate change
itself right so as I mentioned uh if we
measure for let's say one month we have
an area where we have some biomass right
and after 1 month or two months we
measure the same area and uh our
prediction is very less right so that
will give us an indication that there is
there's something happened right uh
probably deforestation or there can be
some kind of uh you know climate event
that wiped out the trees you know uh we
can we'll more analyze more into that
what happened but it will be a starting
point for us to measure the effects of
climate so yes that's ultimately the aim
of this
thing okay
sorry so you said though your your
training data are the are from lar CU
that can figure out the height but you
could have a a tree with a pretty small
Trump in a big canopy or a very thick
Trump in the same size canopy so how are
you getting good
estimation yes that's actually a very
good point uh that is one of the uh you
can say challenges of our of our
approach uh because as I said uh we use
the satellite imagery um main reason is
that because it's free right and it's
it's very scalable it's all available
all over the world uh but as you said
you you cannot really uh infer the
height from the satellite imaging it
only has all these different wavelengths
so our assumption is that these
wavelength are somehow correlated with
the uh with the
biomass uh one other factor which
obviously the biomass will be affected
by as you said is how tall the tree is
and how how big is the canopy what is
the area all of that stuff uh since we
don't have uh the height information
from everywhere in the world we only can
now rely on uh just the satellite
imagery so that is one of the uh you can
say points that we can include in in the
future but that's that's a challenge
yeah yeah and also the basic label data
is built using different plant function
types in different parts of the world so
at a high level you know like if you
look at the tropical forest they're
going to be very different from what we
have here for example so these trees are
definitely taller here then if you go
into the topic so that those are kind of
things that I'm not a forestry expert
but they have actually built this along
with uh those export um but yeah and
that's why we're also looking into
bringing other sources of
energy um I just wanted to know um so
when you when you look at the imagery
from leaf on season does the carbon
sequestration change um during Lea off
and do like uh Force fires uh perhaps
like affect the this yeah yeah they do
they do so uh as I said earlier like uh
usually during Leaf off a leaf on season
we will have more carbon and uh for the
same year let's say and after a few
months if it's a leaf off season uh the
carbon uh will be a little bit less and
also if uh there has been some kind of
desertification or deforestation that
will also uh result in uh reduction of
carbon okay I have a followup question
which areas do you focus on uh
predominantly so this approach is built
for anywhere in the world so this can be
applied to estimate the car carbon
anywhere in the world uh it depends on
uh the client or whoever is applying
this uh where he or she or you know user
wants to focus on and for what purpose
they want to focus on that's a separate
story but basically this this thing this
approach is only to estimate the carbon
anywhere in the world for any time range
that you want uh using this particular
imagery
need to move ahead yeah sorry okay so
let's talk about the challenges with the
ji which is the lar data so uh basically
as I said because the liar sensor is
placed on the ISS uh it can lead to uh
geolocation errors because it's very far
away from Earth and um also there are
some quality filters that uh we apply on
the raw ji data which is recommended by
NASA so are I'll just mention briefly
some of them are related to time of the
day so the sensor is going on like all
the time so there are some observations
that takes during the day and some
during the night and NASA recommends you
should take only the night observations
because during the day it's like it can
get uh noisy uh data because of uh the
sun uh and then there are some uh
aspects related to the sensitivity so
basically um everywhere on Earth uh
different areas have different uh dens
it of vegetation so uh very uh dense
vegetation will require more high power
of the laser to penetrate it so uh
different areas will have a different uh
sensitivity measurement uh which they
the NASA recommends that uh you should
take into consideration as well uh and
as I already mentioned uh Leaf off uh we
don't want to take observations which
are in the leaf off season so we discard
all all of the obervations
so
yes including data could you add to the
biomass prediction by say okay you have
le on you have le off
estimate the reduction of biomass yeah
yes yeah I think that's interesting
point and uh there can be something done
in that aspect so um yeah that's that's
a good
point uh so now let's talk about how we
process the data uh so basically we get
the hls data uh which is the satellite
imagery then we as I mentioned we do the
processing uh to remove the clouds so
that's the cloud free and then uh we
download the ji lar data which is our
labels uh then basically we harmonize
the labels with the hls imagery
harmonized basically means that for each
pixel inside the satellite imagery we
associate the Jedi latitude longitude so
every pixel will have a label basically
and then we create the training test and
validation Set uh so this is just the
same thing in you know picture format so
uh as you can see you can combine
different uh time stamps into one image
as I talked about earlier uh and then
you apply uh the filters on the NASA
data you get uh the harmonized data and
uh so we have I mentioned here something
called as a pulsar so in addition to hls
uh satellite maag we sometimes also use
use additional data sets so one of them
is the Pulsar Pulsar is basically uh
it's a radar based uh data set so like
hls is a data set which uses um
electromagnetic waves uh similarly
Pulsar is also an electromagnetic wave
but it's a a very different wavelength
so it's it's uh useful because it's able
to penetrate uh into the trees and it
gives us additional information about
the structure of the earth basically uh
so it's an additional data set that we
also use uh and then we combine all of
those data sets together we split them
um and then we input that to our
foundation model and the foundation
model gives out a prediction uh on any
any data that we ined any questions on
this
okay okay so uh I'll just talk about uh
different kind of experiments that we do
with our foundation models so um broadly
basically there are are three different
kinds of uh experiments or parameters
that we tune uh the first one is the
your vanilla hyper parameters so uh as
in any deep learning approach you have
you know like uh bat size and learning
rate Optimizer schedular uh size of the
layers number of layers all of these uh
uh common deep learning parameters so
that's the one of the parameters that we
tune uh the other one is usually uh for
uh for foundation models we have
something called as a decoder head or a
decoder part so there is an encoder part
and there is a decoder part so we
experiment with different kinds of
architecture in the decoder decoder head
uh I won't go into too much detail uh
but basically there are a lot of
different architectures available in the
research community in the Deep learning
community and uh we experiment with all
of them to get the best possible model
basically and then of course we also uh
experiment with different uh features or
bands as I mentioned uh we have the hls
bands uh we also have the Pulsar the
radar signal uh we have some other bands
uh imagery U elevations uh stuff like
that which we can also input to the
model um any questions on okay so and
all of this uh experiments all of this
coding is done in the pyge
framework okay so let's talk about how
we measure the perform performance of
these models right so uh one major
challenge with this problem is uh it's a
regression problem first of all right
and the the range of values that this
biomass can take can be very large so it
can be for any area 0 to 5,000 even
right so uh it's very challenging to
measure uh as you know in regression uh
there are various metrics like routine
square error RMC and then RMS percent or
R square and all of these metrics uh we
we mostly focus on rmsc uh or rmsc
percentage uh and then we also have uh
Pearson and Spearman correlation right
uh but the how we how we look at these
metrics is we have a number for the
whole range right let's say we have a
test data uh the actual values in the
test data range from 0 to 5,000 and our
predictions are whatever 0 to 5,000 as
well and we look at the rmsc of this
whole range then we also break down this
rmsc into different bins
uh so we have let's say 0 to 50 biomass
then 50 to 100 100 to 200 and so on
right uh because different areas in the
world uh have different distribution of
biomass as well so uh the user might be
interested in some particular bins which
are more important to get right so we
break down this uh rmscs and all these
metrics into different bins and we
measure U all these things as well and
apart from just the you know numerical
uh metrics part we also look at how the
image looks how our prediction looks on
uh you know like a uh in the image
because it has to make sense right uh uh
that is a very it's a kind of a
subjective approach but it's very
important as well because uh for whoever
the user is uh we look at okay what is
the distribution of the biomass if uh if
something doesn't feel right even if
your rmsc numbers and everything is very
good uh we we can't say that the model
predicted very well because spatial
distribution looks off basically right
so we have to look at all of these uh
aspects of the model and uh for each
model we look at these different results
and then get basically which is the best
one so um how we also compare our uh
results of the foundation model is we
have some baseline models so for example
unit right so unit is just a very common
deep learning uh C DN based deep
learning framework uh which can be used
for classification integration so uh we
keep we train a normal uh unit uh and we
measured our performance against uh this
model and we uh some challenges that we
have uh are basically the as I said the
biomass can range uh has a very wide
range so um
sry question so if I understand
correctly your mole is doing very well
in center of the distribution but in the
tails you are over or
underpredicted that the case is because
of the density in those specific areas
so it is uh it is definitely one partly
because of the distribution uh most of
the time uh we have much more data in
the center and uh since that is what the
model uses as input it will do very well
on the uh central part and as you said
like uh usually in the high AGB range we
have very less data and so uh the model
doesn't have a lot of data to predict on
in that range uh but sometimes it's also
uh the way these uh bands interact with
each other sometimes biomass in the low
range and biomass in the high range can
have very similar uh features so the
model is not able to distinguish very
well they do do they tend to be in the
same area geographical region the low
density and the high density in the same
can like particularly um
particularly if you look at the Amazon
right because of deforestation you can
if you put a whole bunch of these tiles
and train the model you can see like
dense forest you can see like wiped out
areas too it it depends like how
granular you want to go if you take a
big enough area you can get all kinds of
distribution so it is in the bands area
where you're having this discrepancy the
measurement right there
is is not
accurate uh oh no is the measure is
accurate but there is something going on
with deforestation and very dense
vegetation yeah but in yeah in general
in this uh uh this kind of research uh
all the models they tend to over predict
on the low AGB end and under predict on
the high AGB end that's a like ongoing
challenge so uh you know we are also
trying to solve that using additional
data sets and keep improving our
architecture
basically
so uh as as already mentioned uh uh we
don't predict very well on the high AG
or uh it's we we under predict basically
uh and also as I said earlier that we
have very uh few data sets for like
third party verification so we we will
come up with our own estimates right but
how do we know they are right right we
have the the labels which we measure
against but if uh we want to predict for
an area for which we don't have labels
how do we know that uh how good our
model is so sometimes we have some third
party models as well which we can use as
reference uh but uh there are also
challenges with those models that they
can be on in different resolution than
us so it's not a Apples to Apples
comparison but it's kind of like a um um
vashi way of you know like looking at
the
results okay so let's look at some
results now so basically here we have
like a prediction from our model on the
whole globe so the top image is the
biomass and you can see the scale of the
biomass here and the bottom you have the
uncertainity of the same biomass right
so uh and you can see see the scale
there so that's one of the big aspects
of our of our foundation model is that
it's scalable so you can have this
result for for the whole globe
right and then uh we can also go down
zoom in into some area uh so for example
here on the left side we have the
prediction from this uh um geospatial
Foundation model and for reference we
have uh biomass prediction from another
source uh this is basically a data set
from something called as a climate
change initiative it comes from the
European Space Agency right so the space
uh people from Europe right uh but the
challenge here is that this one is at
100 m resolution so as I just mentioned
this a different resolution right but
you can see that uh like overall they
they tend to match right like where we
have high biomass and you know low
biomass but if you zoom in too much
right you will see the differences like
here we have we are predicting a bit
higher biomass these guys are not doing
that right and so there are Regional
differences like here they predict a bit
higher but we predict a bit lower right
so uh that's the challenge that I was
mentioning uh that uh it's very
challenging to see how our predictions
are doing right yeah but here we also
have the advantage of having higher
resolution right and also other
difference is that this one is from 2020
and our prediction is from 2023 so
something can change in those three
years as
well okay so just another uh results
basically it's like we have the
prediction on the same area from a very
basic random Forest then we have a
prediction from the unit
right and then we have a prediction from
the foundation model so again you can
see that there are subtle differences uh
in the prediction right and we have
measured our performance and uh the
foundation model does the best basically
right we measure it uh relative to
whatever labels we have in this
image yeah uh so uh just talking a
little bit about the packages python
packages that we use so as I mentioned
earlier most most of the coding is done
in pdge uh we we use geopal packages
because we work with geopal data so we
have roster iio we have vxr to work with
ti data which is the r data and then we
have uh geopandas uh to work with the uh
Vector data and then we have gal P to
manipulate all these data right and then
we have scipi for all kind of scientific
Computing and our um you know Cy learn
for any kinds of machine learning
Tech
okay yeah uh that's that's the end of
our presentation
so okay